the Joe Rogan experience well they also
don't want to lose the respect of their
friends who are also subscribing to that
same ideology yeah yeah that's it sort
of a man in politics over here in
California if you're if you're not
left-wing if you don't you know just
instantaneously when when there's an
issue instantaneously side with the left
you get chastised and you get called a
racist or you could call the Nazi or you
called a trump supporter or you can't
even have a rational perspective on
things you can't say something like in
hindsight it was a good idea that Donald
Trump closed off travel from China
because it was coming from there and a
lot of people were calling him racist it
turned out to be a good move and then
they've shut it down from a lot of
different places as well you can't say
that so so yeah right so the first thing
Trump does is the the the task force two
days later the travel ban Joe Biden says
the last thing we need is Trump's is in
a phobia then on March I think 12th
Trump suspends travel from Europe Joe
Biden says a travel ban won't stop this
April third Biden says actually Trump
was right about that
now Joe Biden's launching ads saying
Trump didn't go far enough now Nancy
Pelosi is saying Trump should have
banned Americans from coming back in did
you ever see that video where Nancy
Pelosi is talking about telling people
to go to China and tell ya it worse that
video is [ __ ] insane and when they
confront her on it on Fox News I think
was Chris Wallace on Fox News was
talking to her about it she's saying
well the record will show that I was
saying don't be rude to Chinese people
now you were down there encouraging it
yes and the record will show she's such
an ineffective speaker it's so bizarre
that she got to a position of power cuz
she's right she's so disingenuous and so
fake in the way she communicates maybe
especially on those shows maybe she's
just old maybe she was better before I
don't know maybe right that's the
Addyson question this is oh man he had
the Biden question that dudes not even
he's not even here anymore he it's so
weird it's so weird they're pretending
that it's okay that this is gonna be
fine but the way they're defending him
over these allegations is this the
creepy thing under whirring the
allegation early you see Alyssa Milano
when she is what what is this yes she
said deserves due process please
other times what about all the other
people this is it's it's you know I
can't predict what's gonna happen
there's a lot of things that are
changing you know right now that's gonna
affect whether or not Trump wins the
Republicans win or lose but what about
is this weird thing that he wants to do
where he wants to insist on a woman of
color as a vice presidential nominee
wants to I think he said I'm not sure if
he said women of color I think he said
he's guaranteeing it's me a woman and
he's looking at a woman of color I'm not
entirely sure to me that's but that's
absurd
I mean it's nerd if you've got a good
candidate I think you know I don't care
what they look like what their skin
color is their race gender I know a lot
of people on the Left view that is like
short-sighted because and and I think
there's there's decent reasons to talk
about how identity plays you know into
how you've you view the world and the
policies you want to implement I just
think it's dangerous to create that kind
of yeah we're not talking about prom
queen we're talking about someone who
actually has a real important job I
shouldn't pick them based on what part
of the world their ancestors are from or
what gender they are
that's really I would actually say on a
scale of one to 100 that's not near like
the top 50 but I think it is fair to say
that there's a real reason why that
would play a factor play a role like you
you've got a lot of people who have
never experienced certain things and
that includes the left and one of the
big problems I have in politics is what
we see coming from the left is really
based on urban living and from
conservatives on more likely to be rural
living so when you see people on the
left argue for like rent strikes and
things like that
well yeah you're in a you're in cities
where you're predominantly renters so
that's your big issue it doesn't
resonate the same with people who live
in areas where they primarily own their
homes or if you're talking about the
Second Amendment like obviously people
in cities they tend to be liberal they
want gun control yeah because you've got
a very very dense population gun
accidents probably are an issue and
you've got cops within a minutes notice
you live in a rural area the cops are 40
minutes away you need to protect
yourself so this this divide creates a
difficulty in creating policy for the
entirety of the country I could point I
personally would never play someone's
like racial identity or gender in the
top priorities but I do think it's it is
fair to point out that
you know a black woman is gonna
understand things about life in the
black community that a white man's not
going to that doesn't mean you give him
a job because of it you can point out
the perspectives will be different I
agree with both those things right right
that's a good point too in terms of the
overall country is so enormous and it's
so different and varied like to find
some common ground amongst everyone is
so incredibly difficult so it's a
contest of who's got the bigger bigger
bucket
yeah they got electoral bucket yeah
that's a good way of putting it too yeah
yeah it seems like but either way
there's so many people that are just
gonna vote left to get Trump out of
office they don't care you're gonna
elect a guy with dementia you gotta pull
up this article stay alive Joe Biden by
the Atlantic no I'm not kidding when did
they put this man was a couple weeks ago
maybe it's called stay alive Joe Biden
all something and then she said
something like all we need is your
corporeal form and it's it's not not
only arguing that we just need Joe
Biden's body but it actually kind of
argues he's a bad candidate and it's
like it doesn't matter though it doesn't
because we just don't like Trump well
they're right about that he's a bad
candidate Biden yeah they could have
done so much better with Budaj edge with
Chlo Bashar with they'd they're
terrified so Gabbard they're terrified
of Bernie Sanders and Andrew yang I
think probably freaks him out a little
bit too I was I'm a big fan of Tulsi and
followed by yang and a lot of people
didn't like that because you know I rag
on Democrats all the time it's like more
I'll fully admit you can criticize me
all day and night I'm very you know much
see Pelosi and shift Nadler and like you
know the problems we have with them and
I'm not a fan of their policies I think
they go you know they'd either do
nothing but you know within that I saw
Andrew yang and his website the list of
things he's gone through what he's
thought about was was insane I mean the
dude had a policy for everything was a
brilliant guy absolutely and he's also
not a politician so his approach is
going to be from a guy who's an
entrepreneur right a guy who looks at it
in terms of problems to fix you could
you can argue there's a similar thing
there with Trump being a businessman but
yang's listo his he's a comprehensive
list of policy positions was it was
to me I was like I like it I do tulsi
not that guy the thing about Trump is a
giant personality right whereas yang is
a really reasonable person yeah for me
you know Tull sees anti-war stance was
paramount I think the US has wasted too
much money we've got people arguing for
you know fix the pipes in Flint and I'm
like right on let's stop
building weapons and doing deployments
and trying to control these foreign
countries and start working within
America and I think that but there's a
reason why a lot of moderates and
conservatives like Tulsi and it's that
it's it's kind of America first right
you know and why are we applying so much
of our resources and time and energy to
these foreign countries we shouldn't be
doing that well also she's earned that
perspective with two tours of duty
overseas she's served and you know the
Armed Forces she's been a congresswoman
for six years she just stands a lot
about how this works I disagree I
disagree with her on to some of our
domestic policy issues nuclear energy
and well you what is her stance on you
she opposes it well I don't want to
speak for her cuz I'm trying to be very
careful but negative view on nuclear
energy nuclear energy is different than
Three Mile Island right now or Fukushima
we need to understand that when you're
looking at some of these issues that
they have with Fukushima in particular
which is a kind of an antiquated system
that they had set up that they can't
really shut off which I had a whole bit
about how crazy that is
yeah but when you're talking about the
nuclear power that they could implement
today it would be a very different
system right there I'd be fairly clean
extremely high return on energy
investment yeah and zero emissions yes
but there's a fear because of the past
just put it somewhere that sucks yeah we
know where that sucks put a big one
somewhere that sucks and juice up the
whole country with it
[Applause]